[Music]
ow ow
why don't you know take it
slow work it hard make
it why don't you know take it
slow work it hard it
[Music]
why I can see it in your face you're all
over the place can you stand up straight
for me yeah get it back on track if you
want me back to the sweet talk for me
don't you
know it
it don't you know
[Music]
why I can see it in your face you're all
over the place can you stand up straight
for me yeah getting back on track if you
want me
[Music]
back the swe
right why don't you know take it
slow it
it why don't you know take it
slow work it hard make
[Music]
it nice
why I can see it in your face you're
lower than face can you stand up
straight for me yeah get it back on
track if you want me
back theet
[Music]
yeah
crazy okay
[Music]
don't
you
yes
go is it ever going to be
enough is it ever going to be
[Music]
enough is it ever going to be enough
is it ever going to
[Music]
be it's never going to
be is it ever going to be
[Music]
enough luck next time
is it ever going to be
in is it ever going to be
[Music]
in is it ever going
to everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
together at home everybody else said
better luck next time I don't want to CL
the background SC I
[Music]
just I remember when we were gamble into
it everybody else said
is it ever going to be enough is it ever
going to be is it ever going to be
enough going to be to
beever to be
[Music]
the bad
[Applause]
[Music]
girls never going to be
is it ever going to be enough
[Music]
everybody I
[Applause]
[Music]
is it ever going to be enough